I'd like to thank EE 380 for inviting me
and
showing up do interrupt with questions
if you have any when you have any so are
you ready to learn about the hilarious
subject of computability theory see
people are giggling it is hilarious so
let's talk about this an algorithm is a
sequence of instructions executed by a
computer now today we think of a
computer as a machine but originally it
was a person the woman or the man who
executed the algorithm now algorithms go
back to Euclid's elements in classical
Greece and eponymously to al-khwarizmi
in 9th century Persia but it wasn't
until the 20th century that we get
formal definitions of algorithm when
three papers appear Alonzo Church
describing lambda calculus Kurt Godel
describing recursive functions and Alan
Turing describing what we now call
Turing machines all within a year of
each other something already alluded to
it's like busses you wait 2,000 years
for a formal theory of computability and
then three come along at once so why did
this happen
at the turn of the 20th century David
Hilbert in good hangin' was one of the
foremost experts on formal logic which
was just being formed boule having sort
of begun the subject just a little bit
earlier and he had a goal his goal was
to put every single mathematician out of
work because he wanted an algorithm what
this algorithm would do is it would
decide given any statement in
mathematics expressed formally whether
it was true or false
he wouldn't heed mathematicians anymore
you would just need computers that could
execute your algorithm and this was
called V and check do problem because it
sounds better in German now Keith
famously said what is beautiful is true
and true beautiful and Hobart figured
the anti-drugs problem was solvable
because he believed something similar
that logic was sound and complete that
is what is provable is true and what is
true is provable but in fact it one of
the talks at which Hilbert put forward
this idea we will know we must know the
day before this guy had proved that
logic was incomplete which means that
Hilbert was to use a technical term
screwed right so what Goethe did is he
had this incompleteness theorem in which
he showed that he wrote out how you
would go about expressing formally the
definition of this is provable and then
he wrote a formal statement that means
this statement is not provable boy as
soon as you can write that down you're
in trouble right this statement is not
provable so what happens so if it's
provable then
sorry if it's true then it must not be
provable there's something true that's
not approval right the other way around
right if it's false then it is provable
and you can prove something that's false
now that would be really really bad news
that would be unsound but that kind of
belies the whole point of having proof
right the way you prove it and it's true
so hopefully that option doesn't hold
but then you're left with the other
option which which means it's true and
that means there must be something true
that's not provable which is you know
not as bad as being unsound but it's
still really annoying especially if
you're Hilbert now as long as people
thought the anti drugs problem was
solvable you didn't really need any kind
of formal definition of algorithm it
would be just like justice stewarts
definition of pornography I know it when
I see it you just write out your
algorithm yeah that's an algorithm but
if you want to prove there's no
algorithm then you really need some
formal way of understanding what an
algorithm is so the race was on the
first person the first horse passed the
finish line was Alonzo Church and he
came up with a definition of what it
meant for something to be an algorithm
so he said anything you can write down
in lambda calculus is an algorithm and
he had certain ways of representing
numbers in this thing called lambda
calculus and doing stuff with them and
then he showed that indeed that the
introduced problem was not solvable if
lambda calculus was your definition of
algorithm now lambda calculus says we'll
talk about a bit later went on to become
the foundation for functional
programming and I'm a functional
programmer and as was mentioned this is
sort of a theoretical talk and the main
reason for that is that people in
industry have been ignoring what me and
my colleagues have done for years and
years and years
right but recently of course lambdas
have become so sorry here's your
definition of lambda calculus right it's
the world's coolest programming language
because it was defined before there were
machines that were computers and of
course it's the world's shortest it only
has three constructs variables land
abstraction and function application
okay as I said you know people in the
industry have ignored it for years but
all of a sudden right this has become
trendy and languages like Java and C++
and Python all say we've got lambdas
right and there's Duke the icon for Java
looking rather smug well congratulations
Duke you've managed to catch up with
where church was in the 1930s so Creek
doodle remember him was visiting at
Princeton at the time that church came
up with all this and he had a word for
church's solution it was thorough
well actually had two words thoroughly
unsatisfactory to church it look you
come up with your own definition and I
will show you that mine is as good as
yours
so Goodell did that he came up with
recursive functions it was written down
by church's student cleany with
attribution and indeed church and cleani
went off and they proved that what
recursive functions could do land
expressions could do and vice versa so
they were exactly equivalent and they
went back you know which meant that very
triumphant a girdle said look their
duckling equivalent and girdles
responses say oh my definition is the
same as your official inner definition
hmm I must be wrong that thing stood at
an impasse and the impasse was resolved
by this young man Alan Turing who came
up with the third definition what we now
call Turing machines and what Turing did
that was most important that was
difference was not mathematics
but philosophy he explained why what a
Turing machine could do would be the
same as what a computer could do where
computer meant a person following an
algorithm so he gave a detailed argument
with with things in it explaining like
well you must only be able to see a
finite number of symbols at one time
because people cannot distinguish
between nine nine nine nine nine nine
nine nine nine nine nine nine and nine
nine nine nine nine nine nine nine nine
nine nine nine nine
what a lovely argument so he made this
argument and that finally convinced
girdle and all three were proved
equivalent and girdle finally said okay
maybe I had the right definition after
all now philosophers argue about whether
ideas and mathematics are invented or
discovered but well the themes of this
talk is going to be when you have
several things independently coming
together that's powerful or evidence
that you have discovered something
girdle was 28 when he undid the work of
Hobart who was at the time 68 Turing was
23 when he resolved the impasse between
church who was 33 and girdle who was by
then in ancient 30 so all you young
people in the audience you know what to
do it's your job to keep explaining to
your elders when we've got it wrong okay
so that's the background and I'm going
to go on to explain propositions as type
well just pause for a moment are there
any questions yet
okay you're not doing your job right you
young people your other job is to ask
some questions so you don't understand
something tell you why industry has
ignored functional programming that's a
very good question let me go through the
second part which touches on that a
little bit or at least on what
functional programming is a little bit
and we might come back to that at the
end but the short answer is no maybe
they were considering like various other
models of computation not enough for you
that turned out to be equivalent pretty
much all the interesting models of
computation are equivalent to Turing's
and are equivalent to churches I think
there are other reasons why people were
not keen on lambda calculus clearly
certainly talked about the reception for
lambda calculus even among
mathematicians being rather poor so he
switched to recursive functions he said
people like that a lot better
certainly Church did not do as good a
job of explaining why lambda expressions
did what they should do as Turing it.if
explaining why Turing machines did what
was intended but I'll return to that
later it's a good question okay so let's
talk about propositions as types so
we're still stuck in the 1930s and this
guy Gerhard Jensen who is a Nazi but
fortunately that's not part of our story
we're going to talk about his
mathematics he in what was essentially
his doctoral thesis so here's another
lesson for you I'm beep right this is
his doctoral thesis and in it he
introduced natural deduction the main
system of logic that we use to this day
he also introduced sequent calculus the
second most-used system of logic used to
this day and also of
well quantification was already known
and upside-down II for existential z--
was known he introduced the use of the
upside down a to mean for all so there's
a goal for your PhD theses and his key
insight was that the rules of logic
should come in pairs
so his logic was equivalent to earlier
logic such as Hilbert's but he
reformulated in terms of introduction
and elimination pairs and so that's
actually from his paper and if you look
at these rules for and and these rules
for implication I've just rewritten them
here in modern notation and you can see
that the modern notation is exactly
identical to what we have here for and
and implies except I've written my
letters well Jensen wrote his letters in
German and I've written mine in English
so how many people here are familiar
with these rules ok fair sampling but
not everybody so this is beautiful stuff
and very widely used right every
database that you use relies on this
theory just to name one system that
relies on this there another system that
relied on this theory is the enigma
machine that Turing built during the war
drew heavily on ideas about implication
and formal logic so if it weren't for
these ideas we'd all be speaking German
right now ironic I guess even against
intz tendencies so what did he do right
he said ok what does it mean to say a
implies B it means if you assume a if
from the assumption a you can prove B
and these little brackets around a say
well I don't have a proof of a I'm just
assuming a is true and that's
superscripted with an X and the X here
means that this proof rule discharges
the assumption so we have a bunch of
proof we'll so another proof will says
if you have a proof that a implies B and
you have proof of a then you can
conclude B and this is called an
introduction rule because as you move
down the proof you introduce an imply
symbol
this is called an elimination rule
because as you move down the proof you
get rid of an implausible and the way to
think about it is this is all this stuff
you can do once you know about
implication and this is what you need to
know to know you can believe that an
implication holds so similarly for
conjunction if you have a proof of a
into proof of B guess what you've proved
a and B and if you have a proof of a and
B what can you do with it well they're
two things you can do one is you can
conclude a and the other you can do is
conclude B and we can take these proofs
and organize them into trees so here's a
very simple example here's the proof
that B and a implies a and B are there
any questions yet because I'd expect
Sunday at this point to say beyond a
implies an be come on that's completely
obvious well yes it is completely
obvious but it's not one of the proof
rules I gave you so if the proof rules
work we should be able to prove it right
so how do you prove it well to prove an
implication assume B and a so there's
the assumption of DNA and having assumed
being a I can conclude a right
I think assume via there can conclude B
oh now I've got proofs of a and B so
I've proved a and B and I can discharge
my assumption and now I know that B and
a implies an V so the proofs distant
little trees like this I hope that gives
you some sense of how discharge of
Assumption works and if that all seems
really simple good it is that's the
whole point any questions about that now
the other thing you can do with proofs
is simplify them so this proof happens
to be in simplest form but we'll see an
example of a proof not in simplest form
in a minute in fact let me just move to
that so here's the proof not in simplest
form
so here again this is the proof we had
before that B and a implies a and
and here's some proof of DNA so I'm not
going to show you the proofs of B and de
but say there were some proofs of B and
a so here's my proof of B and a and then
from these two things of course I can
conclude and B right but this is a kind
of round about proof because here I've
just mentioned B and a Eric mentioned a
and B and I mentioned B they bit here in
the middle of the proof we've gotten
implies symbol so Jensen want to know
that whenever you did a proof you only
needed to rely on concepts that were in
the hypothesis and in the conclusion so
we should be able to get rid of this
other idea of implies which isn't in our
conclusion and let's assume it's not in
our hypotheses it either so can we get
rid of this well yeah we can
because knows what this is as well
assume DNA oh I don't need to assume DNA
I've got a proof of DNA right here so
let's just use that proof so I'll
replace the two assumptions by this
proof and now right and now I just get
this proof of a and B so I've just
copied this twice to that place in that
place and I don't need these last two
rules I've limited them and now notice
I've got from B and a conclude a and
from B and a conclude beep right there's
a much easier way of doing that because
just here I proved a and just here I
proved B so I get a much simpler proof
so there's a direct proof from a proof
of a and a proof of B of course I can
conclude a and B so we've simplified the
proof so how did we simplify it well we
did two things one is if we had an
introduction an implies introduction
followed by an implies elimination and
what we did is the implies introduction
assumes a the elimination gives us a
proof of a just to place that assumption
by the proof notice that right the
assumption occurred twice so we copied
the proof twice so we're making things
simpler but that doesn't mean we're
making things smaller we might maybe
make
things larger and then the other thing
which is much simpler rights as well if
from a and B you've got proof of a and B
and from that you can conclude a hey
just use the proof of a directly so
those were the two things that we used
in simplifying this proof question great
I have I guess two questions if that's
okay
one is so the little superscript letters
left the brackets we're just using those
to tag different hypotheses right yes
and I guess my next question would be
can we see the implication introduction
rule again I'm just wondering how we go
from I I think I've seen something
similar to this before but normally
presented with like a turnstile where
you can sort of say though if you have
these type ah I guess I'm wondering
that's another way of writing this rule
is we have a white board yeah that's
what you're saying is you've seen the
rule in a different form and the form
you've seen it says if assuming gamma
and assuming a I can prove B then
assuming gamma alone I can prove a
implies B right and and yet more people
tend to use this form much more often
this is actually called sequent notation
but still natural deduction proof people
use this more much more often I like
that one because I don't need to write
it uses less ink basically I don't need
to write gamma every time and this has
gone out of favor but I think it's
actually much more compact introduction
rule it's the same as that it's just
presented if there's two different
notations for describing exactly the
same thing good question thank you
okay so that was what Jensen did and at
around the same time as I mentioned
Church introduced lambda calculus now he
didn't actually first come up with
lambda calculus as a way of describing
algorithms he came up with it as a macro
language for a logic and that turned out
that it was so powerful as a macro
language for a logic you could use it to
write down essentially infinite formulas
and then using something called Curry's
paradox you could prove anything so it
was too powerful as a macro language it
let major proof system so powerful you
could write down the equivalent of
infant formulas and those would let you
prove anything so that wasn't very
helpful for a logic it he already
thought he was onto something right the
first do I have this here no the first
paper that he wrote on lambda calculus
he actually said in it it may be that it
has uses other than just in describing a
logic and that turned out to be quite
right so lambda calculus it turned out
was too powerful and made things
inconsistent but he could make things
consistent again by having type lambda
calculus so the basic problem with
lambda calculus I'm not going to show
this to you in detail but the basic
problem is you can write untyped lambda
terms that don't terminate and so you
had formulas that had no normal formats
or there wasn't a formula there and that
was how you could prove things that
shouldn't be provable so if the proofs
just would always determine if the
simplification of the proofs would
always terminate you'd be okay so he
introduced what was called simply typed
lambda calculus and that turned out to
make the system consistent because it
turns out the terms and simply typed
lambda calculus always terminate so
there you go right Turing shows the
halting problem unsolvable introducing
simple types makes it solvable so
obviously you're restricting your
expressiveness a debt but it turns out
not very
much so let me show you the rules have
simply typed lambda calculus let x be a
variable of type a and n be a term of
type B then lambda xn is a term that
stands for a function with an argument
of type A and a result of type B so a
simple example of this is a might be the
type number n might be the term x times
X which also has type number and then
lambda X x times X is a function from a
number to a number it's the squaring
function clear enough most of you have
probably bumped into this by now yeah
just nod your heads if you're suitably
bored or ask a question if you're
confused okay and then we can apply
functions right so L is a function from
A to B and M is a term of type A so we
apply L to em and we're applying a
function that returns a B so L applied
to M of course as type B and this just
says that the actual argument matches up
with the formal argument required by L
and we can also have a data structure
let's have pairs so if and it's a term
of type A and N is the term of type B
then MN is an a/b pair and if L is an
a/b pair the first of L extracts the
first component whose type of course is
a and second of L expects the second
component whose type of course is B so
let's try to write a simple program and
see how type-checking works
so here's lambda Z second of Z first of
zed and this says well zed is a be a
pair then the result is an a/b pair so
it's just the function that given a pair
swaps its two elements and how do we
know this is type will assume that Zetas
variable of that's a BA pair then second
of Zed would be an A and similarly first
of Zed would be a B so second have said
paired with first of Zed
would be an a/b pair and then lambda Zed
second of Zed first of Zed would be a
function from a be a pair to an a B pair
clear enough
Karl's completely bored cause he has
this backwards before and let's just
look at an example of a program so
here's this function that that we just
gave the type of and let's apply it to
some pair let's call it Y X where Y has
type B and X has type a so that'll be a
B a pair so now here's our function
applied to Y X and we want to evaluate
that so you evaluate this using what's
called the Bayesian rule which says you
just take your actual argument and you
substitute it for your formal argument
so we've done that here and there here
wise wrote Zed I've got my Y X pair and
I've copied the whole proof that that
pair is well typed so now we have a
proof that after we've done what's
called a beta reduction the result is
still well typed so now it's that second
of Zed first of that I've got second of
Y X and first of Y X and of course
second of Y X is going to simplify to X
and first of Y X will simplify to Y and
that's still well typed we can just copy
down the part of the proof that's as
well how do I know this is well type
well because X has type a it's a second
of Y X has type a if we've just replaced
that by X it still has type a and here
and similarly here we've just simplified
the proof so now we've evaluated our
program so the swapping program applied
to Y X gives us X Y and as I mentioned
this process will always terminate and
the first proof of that was actually
written down by Turing Turing also wrote
down the proof explaining that lambda
calculus was the equivalent to Turing
machines I mentioned the Turing machines
were much more popular and most people
thought they were easier to understand
but if you read Turing's own paper on
the equivalence
Queen lambda calculus and Turing
machines pretty much the first thing he
says in the first paragraph is this
proof is very useful because it means we
can do everything
instead of using Turing machines using
quote the more elegant unquote lambda
calculus so Turing had good taste and
then these are just the rules for
evaluating programs so this just says
right well what is lambda xn applied to
a term M it just n with all equal
occurrences of X replaced by M that's
just the notation that means that and
then you can simplify the proof that the
original is well typed to give you a
proof that the result is well typed and
similarly for getting the first
component of a pair now you're probably
getting a sense of deja vu so at this
point I hope the organizers have
prepared things as I asked but could you
reach under your seat
you should find there a pair of colored
glasses they should be rose-colored you
didn't do this okay well you have to
imagine putting on your rose-colored
glasses and when you do so of course
everything that's in red will go away
and what you'll see of course is that
this did you take away all the bits in
red looks exactly like this and that
everything we've seen right if you take
away the red stuff you get what we saw
previously
so it's this exact correspondence right
between what Genson did and what church
did now that wasn't actually recognized
until quite a bit later that's what's
called the Curie Howard isomorphism
which says that well functions are the
same as implication product spaces are
the same as conjunction also it turns
out that disjoint union
or variants are the same as disjunction
and the empty type is the same as false
that's a diagram due to Luca car deli
back from when he did type theory this
was written up so Haskell curry
discovered something similar but not
exactly the same thing and then this
correspondence between lambda calculus
and natural deduction was written down
by William Howard in Xerox notes that
circulated in 1969 and didn't appear
until this paper was published in 1980
in a fest refer to curry so I bet
everybody sitting here is going they get
it that's completely obvious didn't they
see that at the time well no we know
they didn't see it at the time the way
that we know is remember I said against
and introduced two forms of logic
natural deduction and secret calculus he
introduced sequent calculus in order to
prove this idea that proofs are not
round about this idea that if you have
hypotheses that mention some formulas
and a conclusion that mentions some
formula you can always normalize your
proof so that it only mentions your
hypotheses and your conclusion and parts
of those the sub formulas so this is
called the sub formula principle and he
described this in his original paper say
it's very important you could always do
a proof that is not roundabout that's
the English translation of the world
like you use I actually haven't looked
up the German word does anybody know it
no I have to look that up but anyhow you
want to show that there were no
roundabout proofs but he didn't do it
the way I just showed you he did it by
showing an equivalent to sequent
calculus and showing the sequent
calculus satisfy something called cut
elimination which is the equivalent of
the normalization rules I showed you and
in that way demonstrate the sub formula
property so it's irony time right he
needed a row
about proof to show that there were no
roundabout proofs
it wasn't until 1965 that profits came
up with the direct proof and then
shortly after that in the 70s this
correspondence between natural deduction
and natural deduction and simply typed
lambda calculus was discovered so this
is often called the Curie Howard
correspondence other people were
involved as well if you look at the work
of the intuitionists even before the
1930s in the 1920s they were saying
similar things they say implication is
what does it mean to prove that a
implies B it means you have a function
the given of proof of a returns a proof
of B what does it mean to prove a and B
it needs with a pair of proofs one of a
one of the what does it mean to prove a
or B it means either you have a proof of
a or you have a proof of B and that's
why they were in the intuitionist
they didn't accept that not a or a was
provable because they didn't know he
wouldn't have a proof of not a or a
proof of a you just had a proof of not a
or a so that's why they were called the
intuitions so anyhow lots of people say
well Korean Howard were great but maybe
some credit should go to broer hiding
and Kolmogorov the intuitionists some
people say maybe credit should go to des
moines was the first person who actually
wrote out a proof system and
independently of korean howard expressed
these ideas so propositions as types is
a very handy name that distributes the
credit equally and that's why I started
using that name instead but you're free
to use whichever name you want called
the BHK correspondence called the curry
Howard correspondence call it the curry
howard de boigne correspondence as some
people do
so yes logic and I eat is P and not P
and like you a psychologic yes one
contradiction um let's not go there just
now I'll say a little bit about
classical logic in a moment
yes so the name for this is propositions
as types but we can see very importantly
it's not just about propositions as
types it's also right about proofs as
programs and even more than that right
it's about normalization of proofs as
evaluation of programs one way of
expressing all these ideas is in
category theory and turns out that these
are the type level of categories this is
the arrow level and this is two
dimensional categories we have arrows
between arrows so it's a fairly deep
concept right and many people have said
right it's not just the curry Howard buy
action it's the curry Howard isomorphism
right it's not just that there's a
one-to-one correspondence between these
things but there's a one-to-one
correspondence between the structures
that relate them and a one-to-one
that relate those so that's why it's
such a cool idea now when I first saw
this cool idea I thought that's cute
that's some kind of coincidence well I
didn't think is you know the standard
scientists question I wonder if this
happens anywhere else and what I
certainly didn't think was hey I think
this is going to be the basis for my
research career but that was kind of
what happened and the reason why is
because it doesn't just happen for
natural deduction in simply typed lambda
calculus but for pretty much as is
mentioned at the beginning every single
logical system you can name there is a
corresponding computational system and
I've mentioned just a few of those
correspondences there one of the
interesting ones is that the classical
intuitionistic and editing of girdle of
course
to something called continuation passing
style which is a standard implementation
technique and this actually gives you an
interpretation of classical logic so if
you have cold with current continuation
which is an operation in some
programming languages you can use that
to implement the proof of the law of the
excluded middle so it turns that
classical logic falls under this there
are lots of different kinds of modal
logics one of those gives you monads
which is a very standard way of dealing
with things like State and exceptions in
functional languages it's also used for
dealing with concurrency in things like
F sharp the one of my favorites is that
like the fact that there's a
correspondence between logic and
computing means that we should expect
that every good idea in computing has
already been discovered by a logician
and indeed this is what happens right so
that when Milner came up with this type
inference algorithm for on the
functional language ml it turns out that
had already been done by Hindley trying
to understand certain aspects of logic
so the system is now called the
hindley-milner system and when Reynolds
came up with polymorphic lambda calculus
which corresponds to generics and
languages like Java and indeed my
knowledge of what Reynolds had done got
fed in through the team to the design of
generics for Java it had already been
discovered by the logician Gerard who
had done an isomorphic system called
System F and now often this is called
the Sharad Reynolds calculus so what is
curry Howard
it's a double-barreled name that
predicts the existence of other
double-barrelled names such as
hindley-milner and Jerrod Reynolds
so pretty much every functional language
you can name has lambda calculus at its
core so this is kind of my invitation to
you to go off and learn one of these
languages now all of these legs so
you've seen my argument here right this
is a repetition of the earlier argument
three times people found the same thing
that means it's discovered not invented
twice independently people find natural
deduction and lambda calculus and they
turn out to be isomorphic that's a
discovery and again right it doesn't
just happen once happens lots of times
happens for hindley-milner happens for
gerard reynolds again and again the same
thing is discovered by different people
so I will not say there are not bits of
these languages that are invented they
all have bits that are invented but they
have a core that is something that is
discovered now probably most of you use
programming languages other than these
and those languages many of them I would
say are not discovered they are invented
and you can tell can't you so this is my
invitation to you to go off and learn a
programming language that is discovered
yes language that I'm aware of that I
don't see there is boxes F P or his oh
no oh this is F P yes so that was a
wonderful theoretical language it was
highly influential it wasn't really
implemented and widely used I've given
here a list of things that are
implemented and widely used implemented
and distributed this is a list of some
functional languages not a list of all
and you've just mentioned an important
historical one that I've omitted real
languages like Java and C++ okay
escape from ideology and triumph so this
is a repetition of the earlier question
right how come we don't all use this
stuff I think the weight of this falls
on the functional programming community
we didn't do a great enough job of
explaining to other people how you can
use this to do everything maybe so so so
I was the reason I'm here in the Bay
Area is so I can attend Kai right I'm
not really a human-computer interaction
guy but they had a workshop on
programming language usability and the
idea is let's do scientific experiments
to empirically measure what people are
more productive with right what is a
better language design and possibly from
that we can begin to work out
scientifically whether or not functional
languages are actually a good idea so I
take the fact that they are discovered
rather than invented is powerful
intuition or suggestion that they might
be but that doesn't save you from doing
the experiments you have to do the
experiments now you could say well wait
a minute wouldn't it just be the case
that whatever is more effective people
would use that was actually why I
thought back in graduate school that
back in graduate school first I thought
let's do empirical measurements and I
found some papers people had written
about doing empirical measurements about
functional versus imperative languages
and they were all very consistent here
was the consistency between them
if the introduction said we think
imperative languages are better that's
what the paper showed if it said we
think functional languages are better
that's what the paper showed so I
thought hmm
this is gonna be hard all right let's
just wait and see what languages people
end up using people end up using the
better languages I didn't really
understand about network effects
all right Network effects means that if
something is popular
the next thing to become popular will be
the thing that's like the first thing
and you can look at that and see right
and that's why si begat Java and Java
began JavaScript so one reason why it
might be the case that things that
aren't the best dominate could be things
like network effects and does that prove
functional languages are better nope we
don't have that proof I'm hoping that
one outcome of this workshop special
interest group at koi will be to begin
the effort to find that out and you know
it's very hard right I just mentioned
that the first studies are really
inconclusive we're just beginning to
begin to amass some evidence for things
so they're much simpler than functional
versus imperative so this is a program
that's going to take a long time right
but it's just like function language
right function languages used to be
really slow that's another reason people
didn't use them they used to not have
good libraries that's another reason
people didn't use them they used to not
have debuggers all you need to just keep
doing the same thing for 30 years and
you'll get a lot better at it so I'm
hoping we'll begin to do and so these
things which it used to be you couldn't
practically use them now people you can
practically use them right so one reason
perhaps why they're not widely
practically used as well didn't used to
be the case you could now it is but you
know this of course cuz you saw the law
so wait and see wait and see if we can
dominate over the network effects wait
and see if we can actually build up a
body of research and that'll be a long
program you know the way to do anything
is just start go on and keep at it for
30 years
so come back in 30 years we might have
an empirical answer as well yeah in
traditional languages people frequently
confuse with better whether the language
is better or actually whether the
implementation is better what's the
equivalent in functional languages I so
the question was people often confuse
whether the language is better the
implementation is better what's the
equivalent for functional languages and
as I just mentioned it used to be the
case the implementations of functional
languages were rather slow and used a
law of resource compared to imperative
languages that's not nearly as much the
case now so I think that's the
equivalent of what you're asking about
so it used to be these things weren't
very practical but they're becoming more
practical and also of course functional
languages often work better in the
presence of concurrency because you're
not trying to write have many processes
write on the same memory which is a very
difficult thing to analyze so there's
beginning to be much more interest in
functional languages in industry for
that reason so let's just wait 30 years
and see what happens
yeah the presentation of lambda calculus
they gave or like when we were defining
function application we were textually
substituting the value of the parameter
inside the body of the function so
that's what is it passed by name of
semantics oh my name is in efficacy and
semantics what what sort of changes if
you if you evaluate the argument first
before you stuff it if you evaluate the
argument first it's called Kol by value
and back when I first started to do this
there was a nice equation theory of call
by name there was not a nice equational
theory of call by value now there are
nice equational theories of both in fact
I made some contribution to that so you
can just look those up and find theories
foremost you can do it either way now
and if that's right call by name of
course is horribly inefficient what we
do in languages like Haskell which is
called by need is you make clever use of
pointers so that you evaluate each
shared set term at most once
yeah I have an empirical hypothesis that
I think it's going to be played out in
the next five years and that is that
what the functional languages is in fact
missing is is concurrency and that
that's going to be deadly as the number
of course goes up we're just in the
beginning right now you know we get
maybe 60 once we get 100 200 cores on a
chip then this thing's going to die
so some of these languages like air lock
language neither is Scala
so there will be greater interest in
languages that support concurrency -
that's right that will be only way to
get performance so you say the
functional language if you said purely
functional languages will die in five
years because they won't be able to get
performance which is what you say not
really no I think that the functional
languages that will attract a lot of
interest will be ones that support
concurrency in one way or another why
don't I finish the talk and then we can
have debates like that over dinner we
will wait has concurrency fit into this
well that's my day job it turns out
right so I work on something I have a
large grant in the UK called
a program grant shared with Glasgow and
Imperial to look at something called
session types which are an approach to
concurrency and I got interested in that
yeah I always knew concurrency was
interested but lots of people do
concurrency what can I contribute ah
well it turns out that bending and Karis
discuss re pending in Karis discovered a
correspondence between linear logic and
session types so I thought right I
should be all over this because
concurrency is really important
all sorts of problems with session types
yes but it's a way into concurrency that
has this logical foundation right let me
just wrap up so there are lots of
functional languages by the way the same
technique since they can be used for
proofs can be used to represent proofs
so pretty much every proof assistant
that you can name make some use of these
ideas as a way of representing proofs
and this comes up a lot in things like
caulk which has now been used for things
like proving C compilers correct and
proving operating systems correct or
meet certain specifications if you want
to know more about this there are many
many places to go one place you can go
is this paper published in
communications of the ACM in December of
last year and there's lots of other
citations there if you want to look at
other things I'm certainly not going to
claim this is the only or even
necessarily the best place but it might
be useful starting off point if you want
to know no more so let me conclude and
since Turing's big contribution was
philosophy I'm going to conclude with a
little bit of philosophy what would
happen if we tried to talk to aliens so
we've actually done this this is a
plaque on the Voyager spacecraft that's
right pioneer thank you thank you for
the correction right so this is trying
to convey some information here's a map
of where the Sun is relative to various
pulsars the length of the line is the
distance to the Pulsar it has little
marks on it that you can barely see here
which are in binary the frequency of the
Pulsar this is explaining where the Sun
is and then this bit here so that's
pioneer in the background and that's two
people in the front right and there now
when aliens understand this right so
aliens could probably work out the
notion of length they could probably
understand binary what about this bit
well right if star trek is correct then
the aliens will look at it and go oh
they look just like us
except they don't have pubic hair but
other than that they would just like us
alright it might be the aliens are
really very different and they can't
perceive this at all and they don't
really know what to make of this so Sun
bits we can be pretty sure seems likely
they'll be able to decipher other bits
it's less clear so what about lambda
calculus what about extending programs
to aliens
so Independence Day is a movie and in it
the aliens are destroyed by a computer
virus here's a screen capture of the
computer virus and you can see that it's
written in C it's written in a dialect
of C that only has open curly braces so
what are the chances right that you
could give a computer virus to an alien
computer in C probably not large
probably aliens do not already program
their computer s'en see what is the
probability what if you sent aliens of
program in lambda calculus now they
might well not understand the symbol
lambda right but you can do it in a way
where they can just work out distinct
symbols they could probably work out how
to parse it they could probably work out
and you know I would claim it's quite
likely that they would be able to
decipher what lambda calculus is if you
sent them a program in C maybe they
could maybe not sorry
with their virus chequered capture shape
that's a different issue but but anyhow
making an analogy right I'd say lambda
calculus is like this they're likely to
understand it see much less clear
whether they would understand it or not
so
does this mean we should call lambda
calculus the universal programming
language well let's think about that for
a minute these days actually it's become
common to talk about multiverses this is
from a play called constellations but
normally a play has complicated stage
directions the stage directions for this
player very simple it says when you're
reading the play a horizontal rule
stands for a change of universe so it's
a play whose action takes place across
many universes scientists make use of
multiple universes write things like the
strong electron constant it turns out
its value if it was much larger or much
smaller matter wouldn't Co hare
so why is it that this constant happens
to be just right for matter to go here
well maybe they're lots of universes
maybe and most of the matter doesn't go
here we happen to be in one of the ones
where matter does go here because we're
here to see it so the fact that the
universe can be observed might explain
why those constants have the values they
do or in the range they are so
scientists actually make serious use of
the idea of multiple universes so what
about lambda calculus so I can imagine
right different universes wait where
gravity is different or the strong
electron constants that's I at least
find that easy to imagine my imagination
is not so good when it comes to
imagining a universe where modus ponens
doesn't hold that's the law of arrow
elimination with the basic rules of
intuitionistic logic don't hold aren't
no can't be talked about
I find it very difficult to imagine such
things other people might have a better
imagination but I just can't imagine
that right so we can't I'm sorry I'd
like to say lambda calculus is the
universal language but I can't and the
reason why is that calling lambda
calculus Universal is simply too
limiting so that's it
and I'll just to summarize the summary
what you should think is that if you've
have a hard problem to solve maybe one
involving multiple computers then you
should think that this is a job so
that's it unless people have more
questions I'm Maria yeah I wouldn't
expect any other questions in this
audience you guys are so short I think
telling people no side effects is kind
of extreme I keep telling people I like
a separation logic stuff where instead
of saying none you just have to describe
what side effects you have what do you
think of that approach um so okay so
several people have mentioned pure
versus impure functional programming
I've not mentioned it and one reason why
is remember I mentioned that modal logic
corresponds to these things called
monads and modes are perfectly fine way
of dealing with things like State and
exceptions or even concurrency so
they're not necessarily the best way of
dealing with concurrency I would agree
with that but the and linear logic then
gives you a different way of doing it
and if you want to make the point
neither of those give your favorite way
of dealing with massive concurrency I
would agree with that and there might be
other ways Yeah right but we
so far as if this is a normal sleep but
once you get to that question before I
answer your question
so in fact side-effects can crop up
using these approaches now how does that
compare with separation logics so I kind
of like separation logic it comes from
linear logic so it has its roots in this
body of work so even if it turns out
separation logic wins I'm going to claim
a win for theory separation logic is
very much about banging on a single
shared memory and as karl has pointed
out and as I mentioned banging on a
single shared memory is maybe not a good
way to actually talk about very
concurrent systems so that's the one
thing against the eye of against
separation logic it's fine for when
you're talking about a single shared
memory but I don't think that works so
well if you want to talk about very
diverse concurrent systems so we'll have
to wait and see but certainly it's love
interesting work happening in that area
and there will continue to be and what
the best way is to bring concurrency to
the masses remains to be seen but for
very simple cases functional languages
work really well as we all know because
MapReduce was inspired by ideas from
functional languages yes there are
something out gets to session types for
I find logic oh good question
is there something analogous to session
types for upon logic and the answer is
yes it's called a fine session types and
in fact many of the people that do
session types makes an affine and I
serve jump up and down and say no I
think it's better for them to be linear
but both approaches work I should
mention the limitations for say session
types are about trying to give types
that describe communication protocols so
session type very simply it might be
this channel I'm going to send
a value of type a and then receive the
value of type B and then I'll send
another value of type C and then maybe I
will offer a choice between two
protocols and then of course on the
other channel right if this channel
setting and I hate this channel we have
to receive an AK if this channel is
receiving a B this channel better send
to B if this channel is offering a
choice between a C or D this channel
better be making a choice between the C
and D turns out that those that notion
of duality corresponds exactly to
duality between the connectives of
linear logic and so you can use sister
express certain protocols and the fact
that it corresponds to a proof that
normalizes guarantees great properties
you have no races you're guaranteed to
terminate this is fantastic of course
it's also awful because you're
guaranteed to terminate and that there
are no races and you know sometimes you
need a race sometimes you need something
that runs forever so how to extend
session types to deal with those very
important situations is an open question
so I would not want to say session types
are the answer I just think they're very
interesting approach because of this
correspondence to linear logic that's
again you know there are loads and loads
and loads approaches to concurrency
what's the right one so if we can say
well this one corresponds to logic in a
certain way that gives us perhaps a
reason to believe it might be a good way
to go and you know just like it's lambda
calculus better than imperative
programming that has to be tested
empirically but it gives you a powerful
imaginative boost in a certain direction
to the main source we have another
problem
maybe the Internet of Things where we
have a bazillion little local machines
here in the neighborhood each with its
own local states and functional
programming doesn't work for that either
program they send messages back and
forth to each other that's our model of
computation yes purely functional
programming works fine if you use and
to represent political statement there
might be other ways of James re wait
wait wait wait wait sorry the Monad
linearizes everyday you have to pass
that state along hippity-hop hippity-hop
it's crazy
okay sorry but that's no good because
they're crazy crazy they're just many
applications of monads are linear the
basic monad operations are linear but
there are other related structures
called there are other Carl just let me
finish the sentence there are other
related structures called applicative
structures which are related to mine as
it said a similar notion Simon Marlowe
who works at Facebook did a little DSL
library based on the idea of monads and
applicatives for doing filtering every
time you look at a message on Facebook
that's been filtered by this software
using the DSL that Simon Marlowe and his
colleagues have written and that's all
written in Haskell using monads and
duplicative so at least sometimes this
can be put to practical use
I don't know languages if I want to
write a important real program and
wanted to make sure that it was going to
work correctly and I'm willing to pay
factors of 10 or something in the
performance mm-hmm you know consider the
software runs your airplane or drives
your car people are often not really
good it's after 10 for those but ok I
got a better chance of being able
improvements going to work correctly so
the question won't pick the question
right if you work in a functional
language you have a better chance of
proving properties of the software
writing the best way to evaluate that is
to look at the diff
first people have done and the answer is
if you look at something like with the
existing largest proof that an operating
system meets its specification the way
they did that was they wrote the
operating system in Haskell and then
translated it from Haskell to C but they
did the proofs at the Haskell level so
there is at least some evidence that
working in functional languages does
indeed make it easier to prove various
properties if you look at the proof
sorry in that this is the STL for work
they know they know they did they prove
properties of the actual code they
generated right but they structured it
by writing a Haskell program if you look
at the proof of AC compiler that it's
correct and by Davila Roy and his
colleagues that was all done in Cork and
their model of what the compiler does is
a functional language so functional
languages do have a good track record of
helping people to structure these
realistic these proofs of real systems I
won't say you can't do it another way
but I guess I would say that the one
case I know for proving an operating
system and the one case I know of
proving a realistic compiler we're done
with functional languages good question
thank you
but most programmers are dysfunctional
because worse is better well I mean this
is certainly one of the issues which
take up a functional languages which is
training people want to do what they
know and you know maybe not even
unreasonably they want to do what they
know and many people don't know
functional languages but that's
something that an educational
environment can help fix yes so
programming lets they teach programming
to kids what would I use as language so
take slightly older kids freshmen
prefreshman and burn we do teach Haskell
first than many in in the UK not most
places don't teach foreign languages
first but Edinburgh Cambridge Oxford
Imperial all teach functional first so
that seems to work quite well now for
younger kids the best place to look to
see examples of that being done is
Matthias Eliza and the racket crew are
very keen on teaching programmers
programming to high school games so they
thought environment hold doctor racket
it has it's great for building games and
so on they have a purely functional
style for building games in racket
rackets not a purely functional language
but they begin by teaching the purely
functional subset of it to people in
high school not sure they've gotten down
to five or ten year olds yet but I do
think it's very important for teaching
to people that young that you have good
support for things like graphics and
animation and so on functional languages
can do a great job of dealing with that
but we don't have many systems that
actually do it in a robust way that's
good for handing to kids
dr. rackets one of the few we need more
of those so that we can we are a better
choice for getting to people earlier
otherwise the fact that things like
scratch have such fantastic interaction
and graphics might well dominate over
the fact that they're not functional so
I agree the environment is very
important as well and we need better
functional environments for teaching
together it is it's difficult to teach
your young kids scratch because their
logic is not logical they claim
concurrency but it's sequential but that
confuses kids they believe the concerns
and that says is concurrent it's
confirmed okay that's an interesting
thing I think that the concepts of
programming actually I'm not going to
claim that functional programming is all
there is I am going to claim that it's
really interesting very worthy of
attention anybody ever think you can
implement Linux and a purely functional
language well as I do brands SEL for the
one formerly validated operating system
they began by writing Haskell programs
but that's a different question as to
what do you think dipped in a purely
functional in purely functional house
goal you could implement Linux
ie the way it really works today well
since Linux is the default operating
system now and in the future it's kind
of good
it's not different what's the point
merely what the Internet of Things is
going to run on you can't dismiss that
in in functional programming if it just
really can't do it then
you